so in the final video on
select discrete time some markov chains
i could i'll consider
some rewards and expected so
reachability for
our dtmcs so
so here we're gonna augment our dtmc
with
such rewards or conversely
select costs so these are real value
so quantities that we assign to either
the states or and all the our
transitions
of the our dtmc and these can have a
wide range of different
interpretations so just to give you some
slight examples we can use them to
represent the it's like elapsed time
power our consumption so this can either
it's like correspond to so the power
that we consume
in a state or the power that is are
consumed when we make a
transition we can use it to
find out that it's like the size of um a
our message queue we can count
the number of select messages that we've
successfully
sent we can measure it's like a profit
and there's many other
examples so i will call them
it's like rewards but they can also be
have a negative interpretation as
it's like select costs so mathematically
it doesn't make any a difference um
but you would think that if it was like
costs then you'd be trying to
minimize them while you'd be trying to
maximize
rewards so let's formally
so define what it is to give a select
dtmc
it's a reward structure so we have a
both a state
so select reward sub function
so this given given some state it will
select return a real valued um
it'll return a real select value
and we also have a transition select
reward
select function that given any
states gives a real value
which is the reward it's like
accumulated when we perform that
transition
so just to give some concrete example
if we wanted a reward structure for
time slot steps um then
the state so reward function wouldn't
wouldn't be
used and r would give um
would give the real value one for every
transition
if it's like we wanted a reward
structure for the number of lost
messages then we would
um select return one for every
our transition which corresponded to
losing a
select message for power uh select
consumption that i've
already mentioned then the state
select reward function will be used to
select to find the per time step
energy that's like consumption in each
such state and the transition because
that reward
sub function would be used as the cost
of each the energy cost of each
transition so
we need some more select probability
basics so let's go back to there so if
you select recall
a probability space is a
tuple where we've got a sample space and
then we've got
the it's like event set and then we've
got a probability
it's like measure which given any it's
like event gives the probability of that
event
so if we have a real value
select variable over it's like the
probability space
so this this is a
select function but given a
element i a um
so element of sample space this
set returns a real
slap value then we can consider that
it's not expected or average value of
the random
variable so this is given by we take a
slight integral over all elements of
the sample space and then it's um
with select respect to the probability
select measure so if
if we've got a finite um
or a discrete
it's like probability space then we can
turn this into a it's like
sum which is just the sum of the
values multiplied by the probability
of them so let's give a concrete
example so here we've got that expected
or average
value of a die when it's it's like
select tossed
so what's the probability space well
this is possible
so value so either it's one two three
four five or six
and the events are just all the possible
subsets of the sample space
and we know that the probability of um
throwing a one two three four five or
six each has equal
so probability of one it's like six so
so the random select variable here
will if we throw throw eight
it's like one what's it so valuable
that's obviously
one and then so on for two three up to
six
so what's the expected value
well it's just the sum um
of the so probabilities multiplied by
other values so this gives us that the
um
expected so value is actually three
and one third so let's now
go on to expected it's like rewards for
dtmcs so we've got
if you recall the sample space for
um the probability space for
our dtmcs it's like the sample space is
the set
of infinite paths so therefore we want
random
it's like variables which are of the
form they take
a sort of infinite path and they it's
like return
a real
value so if we consider any
infinite path then one such
a select reward at one such random
select variable
can can be the reward it's accumulated
so before we reach some target set t
so here it's it's at the random it's
like variable
x so first we must find the first time
that a state t
is select reached and then
it is the sum of both the
state and the transition select rewards
it's like before we reach t for the
first time
however if we never reach the state t
then we just set
the um it's like cumulative
it's a reward to be infinity
so what i'm now going to show you is how
we can compute this um using
graph based analysis and solving a
system of linear
slight equations so here let
let y at s so to know the expected
so value when we start from state s
now if we're already in the
target then there is no rewards to
accumulate so we can set y of s equal to
zero
if s doesn't reach select the target
with
it's like probability one then we can
set it um
equal to infinity
and this just if we have just it's like
one path that doesn't reach select the
target
then this path will have so the value
infinity and therefore the sum will have
so the value
infinity and
for so other states we do it are
recursively similar to the case of
probabilistic it's like reachability
so um it's
from state s it's the state it's that
reward
it's like associated with s plus the
average or
it's like expected transition so
reward when we leave state s and then
it's
the average of the expectations of all
the
successor states so let's see this in
our practice so let's go back to our um
simple example of
it's like modeling a die with a fair
it's like coin
and here we want to know what's the
expected number of select coin flips
until we reach a a
um done state or a state where we know
it's like
the value of the site die okay so this
is
the expected number of coin flips or
slight steps so we'll associate a
select reward of except one with each
transition
and we won't have any state
of rewards so for all of
other target states then we set
the value ys to be
select zero all of the states
reach um so the target set with
it's like probability one so we don't
set any um
equal to infinity and then
for the remaining states well let's
first look at s
select zero so here we've got the sum so
we've got
there's no state a reward and then
there's
um it's the average
or that of the
transition select rewards so it's one
half times one plus one half
times one and then we've got one half
times the
expected a reward for
s1 plus one half times the expected
reward of s2 okay and then we can
let's let's simplify that to this form
given here and if we keep going
i can also show you state um s6
so we get the same thing that we sum
over the
our transition our rewards
and then here it would be
one half multiplied by
zero as this is in the our target set
plus
one half times y of s2
and if we keep first
select simplify then we can substitute
these two
our values um
into the other equations
we can simplify select again
and then select finally we can
substitute
these values into um
s zero s three and s so that's six
and we find out that y of s is like zero
is it's like 11
over 3. so the expected number looks
like it's a coin flips except before we
know it's like the value
of the slap die is 11
over 3. so just to
mention that our complexity here so
here similarly to probabilistic
reachability it reduces to first graph
based
slot analysis so here so we have to find
the
set of states that reach so the target
with select probability one
and then we have to solve a system of
linear
equations for the graph base this is
it's linear in the size of the our dtmc
and then we need to solve a system of is
that linear
it's like equations and as for
it's like probabilistic it's like
reachability this is
a polynomial or it's like cubic in the
size of the
dtmc and again in our practice
we would actually use some iterative
methods as opposed to solving a system
of
linear slow equations
and as for probabilistic it's like
reachability we can
it's like express this select
computation as a least
fixed point so
finally i will mention there are
additional like reward it's like
properties
for example we can consider
instantaneous
it's like reward it's like properties so
these can ask
what's the it's like expected is that
value
of a state it's like reward at a given
at a given time step so for example
what's the
expected cue size after
it's like 90 seconds or so 90
steps or there's also that it's like
cumulative
time-bound properties for example what's
the
expected it's like cumulative so reward
up until time time step k
there's also for those that are
interested there's
long run average and we can have
it's like multi objective
properties that include select rewards
so that finishes the set of
this part of the um
videos and in it's like the next set i
will go on to markup
decision is that processes that extend
dtmcs to
allow the modeling of non-deterministic
behavior